and finally new rule if Megan and Harry
can quit their family you can too not
that I've got anything against families
in general they come in really handy at
times like like when you need a cosigner
for a car loan but the downside of
families is they possess a gravitational
force that gets you to do stuff you
don't want to do and continue traditions
you don't really believe in families
like drugs you get high off them but
they make you do stupid things
Princess Diana famously said she felt
like a prisoner
but many people can get trapped living
their family's life and not their life
captive to the same old jobs politics
region customs you know every New Year's
Day my family used to serve pork and
sauerkraut I don't know why my parents
did it and their parents did it and I
did it until one year I said I hate this
[ __ ]
just because I shared DNA in a bathroom
with you people doesn't mean I have to
live by your rules forever so do it
fire your family Harry gave up a castle
what do you got to lose an air mattress
break the cycle think outside the crib
there must be 50 ways to leave your
mother you don't have to do what your
folks did you don't have to get married
and have children if you don't want to
or go hunting or work in a coal mine you
don't have to be the religion you were
born into or any religion you can
explore an alternative way of looking at
the universe called not batshit crazy
so I give hairy and making some credit
but not a lot because they want to be
seen as this modern couple way hipper
than the others Duffy went to the family
okay then go all the way and say it say
we're not just taking a step back from
royalty we're renouncing the whole
outdated racist anachronistic lot of it
Rick we're saying loud and proud what is
this [ __ ] that some people are royal
you want to be modern and woke and all
that want to get rid of politically
incorrect words how about your highness
what could be more antithetical to
liberalism than calling another human
your highness I gotta say the social
justice warriors who never tire of
pointing out old behaviors and bygone
attitudes that just don't cut it anymore
where they've been on this one seduced
by the pageantry where you I think the
woke had been asleep surprisingly
forgiving about the idea that some
people are born exalted above the rest
of us to be bowed to and cart it around
in golden carriages are you people who
wake up offended where's the outrage for
you I want an apology from the people
always want an apology
did you know the Queen has a grand
Carver currently the Earl of Denby whose
sole job is to carve the Queen's meat
and a dinner when the Queen finishes
eating everyone else has to stop - yeah
when the old bat puts her spoon down
that's it we're all done I thought being
born into privilege was public enemy
number one now but you're happy to be
lorded over by a bunch of inbred twits
who happen to win the 23andme lottery
Megan and Harry you want to be
remembered for greatness then burn your
boats completely and say it's 2020 I
hereby decree this birthright nonsense
from the Middle Ages is stupid and the
next time someone curtsies or boughs and
scrapes before you or calls you your
highness
stop them and say we feel ridiculous
being called that I'm an actress he's a
nice guy
highnesses no humans are higher by birth
it's gross
and to those who say the monarchies too
important to tourist attraction I always
hear that can't abolish it guess what
you don't need live people for it they
still go to Stonehenge and the aliens
who built that left a long time ago
the palaces the guards the carriages
it's practically an amusement park
already we could call it the magic
United Kingdom
fill it with rides like Caucasian
mountain
Diana's Wild Ride
and the tunnel of incestuous love just
you know keep the kids away from Prince
Andrew
you